at least half of the smart people on the
planet are women so I think it's really
important for any company to fully
utilize all your talents and I think
that you've got to understand what what
women are good at and and women are you
know women are not homogeneous and every
woman is different I think understanding
every woman what she's different about
having those communications about what
she's good at and building off those
strengths would be great where I see
people fail as they try to get women to
act in a male kind of way I think that
you've really got to use each person to
their strengths and mentor them and pull
people along and and make sure they have
positions of authority and
responsibility and influence that they
can mentor other women in a company I
think we're really lucky that half the
people in my team are women they run
some of our big and global brands and
quite honestly they do it incredibly
effectively and different from each
other um so I think what we've done best
for them and for the men in our company
is to make sure that they're building
off a position of strength